alors passez vous ici comme ça timothée
n'a que 9 ans mais donne déjà
l'impression d'être un habitué des
studios un appareil autour du cou qui
fait presque la taille de son visage le
jeune apprenti shoot son modèle du jour
un fauconnier dont ils photographient le
portrait est maintenant on va jouer
l'oiseau hockey d'anglais te regarde
sur les conseils de frédéric grah
professionnel reconnu et décorer les
élèves de cm1 prennent en charge eux
mêmes la séance apprentissage express
dans un univers méconnu
on a appris tout ce que tout ce qu'il y
avait dans un studio tout ce que tout ce
qu'on devait faire sur l'appareil photo
les objets que les objets qu'on devait
utiliser dans un studio
j'ai appris en association avec les
itinéraires poétique de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ces ateliers
pédagogiques est allé sur plusieurs
semaines permettent également aux plus
jeunes de travailler sur la découverte
de l'autre et le partage d'expériences
des éléments qui peuvent aider certains
élèves
les enfants sont très contents de
rentrer dans un projet commun ils
peuvent aussi se démarquer sur autre
chose que le travail écrit et justement
pour les enfants très timide ça leur
fait aussi du bien de pouvoir parler de
pouvoir justement essayer de ne pas être
dans le carcan de la classe elle les
portraits des élèves seront exposées
dans les rues de coignières à partir de
la fin du mois de mai